did you know about the history of
christmas do you know have any
i know it's a relatively recent
phenomenon i mean the the idea that you
would celebrate a birthday
is also very modern um in christianity
your your birthday was assigned to the
christened name that you received so
there'd be the the the day of the saint
for after whom you're named yeah and so
i was christened but there's no saint
neal
so there's actually there will be when
you go
i don't think anybody knows this my uh
my baptismal certificate says cornelius
because there's a saint cornelius i'm
actually cornelius degrasse tyson
in the baptismal certificate but i'm
otherwise neil yeah in my birth
certificate
so so your your your birth was
celebrated on the
the day ascribed to that saint um
so the idea of giving birth giving
presents for a birthday
is a is is relatively new now christmas
all right this was a brilliant maneuver
by the catholic church back when all
christians were catholic
and so what do you do you got all these
pagans
they're running around yeah uh when
they're paying
they're doing their pagan stuff dancing
naked around the bonfire
pagan stuff sounds like a good time
that's exactly what i'm going to do
after your master class
yeah i mean the pagans partied a lot
better than the christians did so here's
what happened so
one of the set celebrations um
took place a few days after
the first day of winter okay so uh today
we're around that time around the first
day of winter well what's happening i
don't know if you noticed
but as the winter as you approach winter
the
sun the ark of the sun from
sunrise to sunset gets lower and lower
in the sky
as the days go by that's when the sun
and this
in the summer sun is very high in the
midday in the winter it's very low
shadows are long the ancients noticed
this
as you approach december 21st the ark
got lower
and lower and lower and your sun
worshiping civilization
this is some scary stuff right okay
because if this keeps going
the sun will dip below the horizon and
never come up again
that's scary so what do you do you pray
to your gods
and this the movement of the sun slows
down
it stops solstice
stationary sun armistice stationary arms
okay it's latin soul is the sun
stops so the sun stops getting lower and
then you begin to notice it come back up
that happens a few days after december
21st that happens around december 25th
celebrations abound now you want
everyone to be monotheistic
not multi-theater not um polytechnic
polytheistic
so what you do is you
co-opt pre-existing celebrations
smart move just smart move yeah tactical
mac
tactical marketing strategic all of the
above yeah
so you say well um while the birth of
jesus we think of as a very important
event today
nowhere near as important as easter
easter that's the canon right there
that's jesus dying on the cross for your
sins
the fact that he was born is kind of
incidental everyone's born he's not
really
jesus christ yeah he didn't do his
miracles he's a
baby right all right so but there was
still an unassigned holiday
so let's put the birth of jesus there
it's an unknown date by the way they
think it might have been sometime in the
spring
based on descriptions of the shepherd
shepard shepherds you know
but uh and when they make the pecorino
cheese you know
absolutely yeah the kid went surfing i
mean
it was it was around the bible yeah yeah
so gospel look
um so uh so
to assign that now you can port people
over from whatever was their previous
celebration to a christian celebration
and that enabled it to take a firm hold
and santa claus would come much later of
course he's a modern well when santa
claus started to come it's actually like
anything else that happens great in this
country it came out of new york city
baby
18th century late 18th century thomas
nast he was a
civil war union propaganda artist and he
created
um the the idea the image that image
okay we think of
as santa yeah but it was really a union
soldier with you know toy there weren't
toys it was like
um what was it in his sack it was a
military military equipment and
ten the midnight thing was like senate
is running out of time to re-enlist
soldiers it's
it was a whole propaganda i've read this
long ago but i've forgotten all about it
yeah the the nasty we just teach neil
something i think it just happened
yeah i remember that is very
textured and rich yeah yeah it's like
totally it
yeah right i mean he looks like a just a
drunk irish kid yeah yeah he does well i
mean yeah
yeah he's just drunk irish kids his name
should be shawnee donald yeah
yeah but so often they're traditions and
rituals we think are
deep and long ago but no somebody just
invented them right
and and even the christmas tree is a
secular thing it's just
but it was attached to the christmas
holidays and so now you've got
so the plenty of jewish people have
christmas trees right i know i grew up
in brooklyn jews a lot of jews my all my
jewish friends are christmas trees
so you're jewish greek no i'm all greek
but my friends no you said you were
fourth turkish
i heard that at the beginning of 26 i
paid 26
there's no no you're not getting 26.
that's what they told me no it's 25.
25. yeah because you you only you can
only split by twos right so you're 50
25 12 and a half percent one eighth one
sixteenth
you're not getting twenty six percent
unless you were greek
so long ago that it split into a hundred
parts and you can
divide it that close you're one fourth
greek i'm one hundred percent african
[Music]
yeah nick was actually turkish yeah i
was gonna say i got news for you baby
he's a turkish kid
st nicholas was born in 280 a.d and
patara and the amira in modern-day
turkey
so what are you to do now yeah i mean
the church went again
yeah we really hope you enjoyed that
episode whatever it was about this is
just a stock thing that we're taping on
to every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to
patreon.comridgeboys where things get
really wild